يتوافد مئات من الفلسطينيين البدو ومن
مناطق اخرى من داخل الخط الاخضر الى منطقه
المقر الحكوميه ومجمع المحاكم في مدينه
بئر السعد السبع في النقب وذلك تلبيه
لدعوه اطلقتها لجنه المتابعه العليا لشؤون
فلسطينيين الداخل للتظاهر ضد سياسه هدم
المنازل وتوزيع مئات اوامر الهدم وتجريف
الاراضي وتخريب المحاصيل للمواطنين
الفلسطينيين البدو في صحراء النقب وكانت
السلطات الاسرائيليه كثفت مؤخرا عمليه
الهدم في القرى العربيه في النقب بذريعه
البناء دون ترخيص فقد هدمت يوم انسي اربعه
منازل لعائله واحده وهدمت قبلها بايام
سبعه منازله لعائله اخرى
ومن بئر السبع الان معنا مراسلتنا نجوان
سمري اذا نرى خلفك المحتجون يرفعون
الشعارات واعلام
صفي لنا الاجواء وما الذي يتوقعون ان
تفعله فعلا هذه الاحتجاجات وان تؤثر
نعم هذا ما يتمنونه بالفعل ان تؤثر هذه
الاحتجاجات وهذه المظاهره اليوم امام مقر
المحاكم والحكومه
الاسرائيليه هي للمطالبه بوقف عمليات
الهدم حيث لا يسلم الداخل الفلسطيني ايضا
من تكثيف عمليات الهدم في عهد هذه الحكومه
المتطرفه اليمنيه وهناك تكثيف لعمليات
الهدم ايضا في قرى وبلدات فلسطينيه
للمواطنين البدو في صحراء النقب منذ ان
بدات هذا بدا هذا العام يتحدث
تتحدث الجمعيات الحقوقيه التي تعنى بشؤون
البدو في صحراء الناقه عن مئات المنازل
والمنشات التي تم هدمها منذ بدايه هذا
العام المعطيات تشير الى ان هناك
14,000 منزل ومنشاه تم هدمها في الست
سنوات الاخيره تع ملكيتها للمواطنين البدو
داخل الخط الاخضر في النقب نتحدث عن هدم
يتم في قرى مسلوبه الاعتراف لا تعترف
اسرائيل بوجودها على الاطلاق رغم انها
قائمه منذ قبل قيام اسرائيل منذ قبل عام
48 36 قريه يسكن بها 150 الف مواطن لا
تعترف اسرائيل بوجودهم ولا توفر لهم اي من
مقومات الحياه البسيطه سواء كان الكهرباء
المياه البناء التحتيه مدارس عيادات طبيه
تفتقد هذه القرى لكل هذه الخدمات لكن
الهدم في الاسابيع الاخيره لم يقتصر فقط
على هذه القرى منزوعه الاعتراف وانما ايضا
شرعت السلطات الاسرائيليه بهدم منازل
لمواطنين في قرى تعترف بها
ولكن بدعوه البناء دون ترخيص يوم امس فقط
تم
اربعه منازل لعائله السعايده عائله واحده
فقط وقبلها باسبوع سبعه منازل لعائله
الغول في قريه عرعرت النقب الان ابلغنا
ايضا ان هناك عمليات هدم في مناطق اخرى في
النقب بالتزامن مع هذه المظاهره سياسه
الحكومات الاسرائيليه المتعاقبه هي تهجير
المواطنين البدو
وتركيزهم في اقل بقعه ممكنه من الارض
والغاء كافه
القرى تقوم اسرائيل عاده
تقوم اسرائيل عاده اما
بتجريف الاراضي التابعه للمواطنين البدو
وتشجيرها وزراعتها بالشجار بريه وايضا
باغلاق مناطق واسعه والاعلان عنها مناطق
عسكريه مغلقه وهذه المناطق عاده ايضا تكون
ضمن النفوذ هذه القرى البدويه
[موسيقى]
المواطنين البدو من العيش في اراضيهم
سنتابع معك اذا هذه الاحتجاجات شكرا جزيلا
لك نجوى سمري من بئر السابع في النقب